a few weeks ago as you may remember we
were talking about Dei destroying the
airline industry and how these forc
diversity policies have left us with
incompetent pilots flying planes that
have been shotly assembled and at the
time I said that things are getting so
bad so quickly that soon enough we're
going to find ourselves at a point where
the passengers will have to inspect the
planes themselves before takeoff kind of
like how you quickly rifle through your
bag of fast food as you pull out of the
McDonald's drive-thru just to make sure
they got the order right inevitably of
course they they will have gotten the
order wrong in about five different ways
and you'll have to decide if it's worth
getting back in line to complain about
and then you'll decide it's probably not
so you just take whatever wrong order
they gave you uh these are the kinds of
decisions you'll one day have to make as
an air traveler I predicted you know I
know
that whenever I'm boarding a plane um I
always you know I always try to inspect
the aircraft myself uh from from like
the window in the terminals I I'll look
at the airplane I'll do a little
inspection and then when I when I get on
the plane I look around
and uh I always see things that concern
me I'll see a little bit of uh something
on the plane looks like it's a little
rusty there or something looks so I see
that all the time but every time I see
that I think to myself well you know it
doesn't look good but I mean don't be
ridiculous obviously they wouldn't send
the plane into the sky if if that was
actually a problem so they must have it
under control that's what I tell
myself but now I can't tell myself that
anymore now now I'm wondering if maybe
they really should before we all get on
the airplane maybe they should have all
the passengers just walk around the
airplane to do a quick inspection to see
if we see any dents or loose screws or
anything it's like they do if you if you
rent a car you know you rent a car from
Enterprise they bring you out to the lot
and then they have you do a little
circle around the car uh to check for
damage so maybe we need to do that with
planes too I don't know by one day I
meant apparently in about 12 days
because the day has finally arrived um
like two weeks after after I said it
here we are from the New York Post quote
a new york-bound Virgin Atlantic flight
was cancelled just moments before
takeoff last week when an alarmed
passenger said he spotted several screws
missing from the plane's Wing British
traveler Phil Hardy 41 was on board
flight vs127 at Manchester Airport in
the UK on January 15th when he noticed
the four missing Fasteners during a
safety briefing for passengers and
decided to alert the cabin crew quote
I'm a good flyer but my partner was not
loving the information I was telling her
and started to panic and I was trying to
put her mind at rest as much as I could
Hardy told the Kennedy news agency of
the moment he spotted the missing uh
fixings quote I thought it was best to
mention it to a flight attendant to be
on the safe side Engineers were promptly
called out to carry out maintenance
checks on the Airbus A330 aircraft
before it scheduled takeoff to John F
Kennedy International in New York City
according to a virgin Atlanta rep okay
now uh the concerned traveler Hardy took
video of the engineers working on the
wing of the plane and uh which by the
way is just something you never want to
see at all like you don't want to see
while you're sitting in the plane anyone
fixing the wing but you especially don't
want to see it when it looks like this
watch
he now he's just spreading them
out
did
he no no just
one
um first of all as a casual viewer who
is not at all an expert in aircraft
engineering or any other kind of
engineering it did appear to me that he
removed the screw from one hole and then
screwed it into a different
hole and and maybe I'm misinterpreting
what we just watched there hopefully I
am I must also say that it's rather
disturbing to see the guy using a
regular Philips screw screwdriver I
guess I always assume that they use very
powerful like industrial grade electric
screwdrivers that you can't even find at
at at Lowe's you know to fasten all the
screws and bolts on the plane but but
watching the guy apparently spreading
the crew the screws around because he
doesn't have enough and using a regular
manual screwdriver that he found in his
junk drawer I I like I it looks like he
looks like me clumsily trying to
assemble a side table from Ikea and I'm
terrible at assembling anything that is
not made out of Lego blocks so it's
deeply concerning that I can relate so
much to a video of a guy working on the
wing of a passenger aircraft and it gets
worse uh here's more from the New York
Post quote Hardy said Airline staff
repeatedly reassured him there was no
safety issue with the wing but his fear
was heightened given the recent ordeal
in which an Alaska Airlines plane lost
its door plug and a chunk of its
fuselage flew off mid-flight both virgin
and Airbus stressed there was no impact
to the safety of last week's aircraft
despite the Miss Missing fixings
the Virgin representative said the
flight ended up being asked to provide
time for precautionary additional
engineer maintenance checks which
allowed our team the maximum time to
complete their inspections the safety of
our customers and crew was always our
top priority and it was not compromised
at any point we always work well above
St Industry Safety standards and the
aircraft is now back in surface uh this
according to Neil berth the airbr uh
local Chief Wing engineer for a a 330
added that the affected panel was a
secondary structure used to improve the
aerodynamics of the
plane
um okay got it uh they canel the flight
and brought a team out to fix it but
there was no problem and nobody's safety
was in Jeopardy makes total sense
besides I mean we didn't even need that
panel you know the one that was only
partially screwed on we didn't even need
it that panel was lame anyway that panel
who needs it matter of fact we don't
want that panel we wanted to fly off it
was supposed to become dislodged
mid-flight you see that was supposed to
happen it was going to be an exciting
surprise for the passengers and now
you've ruined it you party pooper you
dork all worried about the
screws this appears to be the the excuse
they're going with are you one of the
millions of American men and women
dealing with premature hair loss maybe
you're scared about inheriting that
thinning look because it runs in the
family start 2024 off right with a real
solution that delivers on his promise
without the harsh side effects unwanted
chemicals and no need for a prescription
provia uses a safe natural ingredient
called prael to effectively Target the
three main causes of premature hair
thinning and loss by supporting healthy
scalp circulation the delivery of
nourishing nutrients and healthy hair
follicles anchoring to your scalp uh
provia guarantees more hair on your head
than in the shower or on your comb it's
effective for men and women of any age
and safe on color treated and styled
hair it's that easy right now new
customers save over 50% plus free
shipping on Provo introductory package
at provia.com Walsh every package
includes a full 60-day supply of provia
serum for daily use plus the provia
super concentrate for faster more
noticeable results and every order
includes your choice of a free gift
right at checkout proval Works
guaranteed or 100% of your money back
don't wait order now and save an extra
10% and free shipping at provia.com
Walsh that's provia.com
Walsh now prefacing this again with an
admission that I am not an airline
safety expert but then again apparently
nobody is anymore I have to ask even if
the panel was not structurally necessary
to keep the plane in the
sky wouldn't it still potentially
jeopardize passengers on the plane not
to mention people on the ground to have
a large metal chunk fly off the aircraft
when it's 35,000 ft in the sky and
traveling 400 miles an
hour like I don't know perhaps I'm just
naive and even something like helping
the it be the plane be aerodynamic isn't
that like important isn't it oh no
that's fine it's just to make the plane
aerodynamic what happens if the plane is
not aerodynamic oh well you know it
crashes
oh so this is where we are we have
officially moved into the phase where
you need to check yourself to make sure
all the pieces of the plane are screwed
on
properly you know maybe you should
actually bring your own screwdriver to
in case the airline can't find theirs
because I assume they all have one they
only have one screwdriver maybe bring a
couple rolls of a duct tape as well just
in case now look it's easy to blame the
situation on Dei and we should they're
simply no question we've seen a rapid
decline in standards and quality as Dei
is taken over every industry and if
you're prioritizing anything but skill
and Merit in your hiring process if
you're doing anything but trying to get
the most competent people regardless of
demographic then you will end up
lowering the standards it doesn't matter
what the Dei apologist say it doesn't
matter what these industries claim you
know of course none of them are going to
come out and actually admit that they're
lowering the bar in order to get more
people who are not white males involved
but that's what has to happen to achieve
the goal and it is what is happening
there's no way around it but it's also
true that uh this problem is bigger than
Dei and you could trace its roots to
long before Dei existed as a concept the
diversity police are exacerbating the
problem they're spreading the disease uh
around and making it worse but the the
fundamental sickness runs deeper than
Dei you as I've been talking about for a
long time a large number of the workers
in basically every field that
exists do not take pride in their work
anymore I mean that's what it comes out
like the basic
effort to do things correctly because
just just for the sake of doing them
correctly um that that is becoming a
rare
mentality you know we complain about
this in the customer service industry
all the time as a customer no matter
what store or business you're dealing
with it's very hard to find someone who
cares about providing you with good
service or solving whatever problem
you're having and most of the
frustration you experience as a customer
is due to the fact that you're dealing
with people who just who they just don't
care about your problem it doesn't
matter to them and maybe they'll help
you solve it maybe they won't but they
don't care and and and that's it uh you
rarely get the sense that any of the
customer service Representatives you're
interacting with are emotionally or
mentally invested in the interaction
you're having with them or in ensuring a
favorable experience for you and this is
why customers everywhere are frustrated
all the time which makes them rude which
makes customer service Representatives
Rudder in turn and the cycle goes on but
you know this is not a dynamic found
only in the customer service realm I
would argue that you can find it
everywhere in every field in the field
that I'm in definitely um in every
industry like just ask yourself how
often in a given week or month you
encounter someone and you think to
yourself wow this person really takes
pride in their craft this person really
cares about their craft now you do run
into people like that but they always
stand out like shining Diamonds in the
Rough because most people don't take
pride in their craft or really don't
have a craft at
all this is the thing underlying the
problem that Dei has made significantly
worse at every turn and why does this
underlying problem exist where is it
coming
from well that's a whole other
conversation entirely for now the point
is simply that people are
demoralized and check
out which is which is really annoying
when you're trying to order fast food or
you're in the checkout line at Walmart
but it's terrifying when you're sitting
on an airplane and getting ready for
takeoff which is why the well I guess
the airline industry is once again today
cancelled if You' like to see what else
I have to say you can access my full
show by going to dailywire.com or by
going to the Matt wallow Twitter page
hope to see you there Godspeed